we will now use the Bayes rule in an
important application that involves a
discrete unknown random variable and the
continuous measurement our discrete
unknown random variable will be one that
takes the values plus or minus one with
equal probability and the measurement
will be another random variable Y which
is equal to the discrete random variable
but corrupted by additive noise that we
denote by W so what we get to observe is
the sum of K and W this is a common
situation in digital communications
we're trying to send one bit of
information whether K is plus 1 or minus
1 but the observation that we're making
is corrupted by a communication channel
by some noise that is present in the
channel and on the basis of the value of
y that we will observe we will try to
guess what was sent the assumption that
we will make about the noise is that it
is a standard normal random variable so
suppose that we observed a specific
value for the random variable Y we want
to make a guess about the random
variable capital K of course there's no
way to guess with complete certainty the
only thing that we can say is to
determine how likely is this that the
one was sent as opposed to how likely it
is that a minus one was sent how do we
approach such a problem well we use the
version of the Bayes rule that we have
already developed and which is this
formula that gives us the conditional
probabilities that we want and in
particular here were asking a question
about the conditional probability that K
takes the value of 1 given that a value
of Y has been observed this is what we
want to calculate so let us look at the
various terms involved here and see what
each term
first we need the prior probability of K
this is simple the prior probabilities
are one-half for k equal to minus 1 or
plus one because we said that the two
possibilities are equally likely then we
need the conditional density of Y given
K okay so what does this assumption mean
it means that Y is a standard normal
random variable to which we add the
value of K so if K is equal to 1 we're
taking a standard normal and we add a
value of +1
so Y given that K is equal to plus 1 is
going to be a standard normal plus 1
what does that do if we take a standard
normal and add a constant to it that
changes the mean and makes the mean
equal to 1 and does not change the
variance on the other hand if K happens
to be equal to minus 1 then the
observation that we see is going to be a
standard normal plus a value of minus 1
and that changes the mean to become
minus 1 but with a variance of 1 so if
we are to plot the density of Y that
density of course will depend on what
the value of K was and if K is equal to
1 then we will obtain a normal that has
a mean of 1 so it's centered here but if
K is equal to minus 1 then our
observation will be a normal with unit
variance but surn centered at minus 1 so
if we are to write this in terms of
symbols the distribution of Y is normal
with variance equal to 1 so the PDF is
given by this form
to the minus 1/2 Y minus the mean of Y
but given the value of K the mean of Y
is equal to K plus or minus 1 depending
on what K is so this is the PDF of a
normal with unit variance and mean equal
to K and it corresponds when you set k
equal to 1 it corresponds to this graph
when you set k equal to minus 1 it
corresponds to that graph let us
continue with the next term in this
expression we need the term in the
denominator which is obtained by taking
a sum over the different choices of K
there are two choices and each choice
has a probability of 1/2 from the first
choice we have 1/2 times the density of
Y when K is equal to minus 1 and when K
is equal to minus 1 we obtain this
expression and we have another term that
corresponds to the case where K is equal
to plus 1 in which case we have this
expression here once more this
expression here corresponds to this
normal with a mean of minus 1 this
expression here corresponds to a normal
with a mean of +1 which is this graph
here so at this point we have in our
hands expressions for everything that is
involved here and we can just apply the
formula and carry out a fair amount of
algebra there are some very nice
simplifications that happen along the
way and we end up with an answer that
has the following form it's 1 divided by
1 plus e to the minus 2y and this gives
us the probability that a 1 was sent let
us try to make sense of
this expression let's see what it looks
like by plotting it as a function of Y
so what we're plotting here is this
expression okay if Y is very large as Y
goes to plus infinity this term
disappears and we obtain a 1 if on the
other hand Y is very very negative so Y
goes to minus infinity here we get e to
the infinity which is a very large
number so this ratio is going to
converge to 0 so we have a graph that
starts at 0 it actually rises
monotonically and in the limit converges
to 1 if Y is equal to 0 then this term
is 1 and we obtain a 1/2 let us
interpret this plot if Y is very large
it is much more likely that Y is coming
out of this distribution so that K is
equal to 1 so the probability that K is
equal to 1 if we obtain this observation
is almost 1 we have almost certainty if
on the other hand Y is very very
negative then it is much more likely
that what we're seeing is coming from
this distribution so that K is equal to
minus 1 and in that case the probability
that K was 1 is going to be
approximately 0 finally if Y is 0 then
we're just in the middle of the two
possibilities and by symmetry either
choice of K is equally likely
therefore the posterior probability that
K is equal to 1 given that Y was equal
to 0 that probability is 1/2 when Y is
equal to 0 it's equally likely that
either signal was sent this example is a
prototype of the kind of calculations
that are done in the analysis of
community
creation systems this is the simplest
model of communication of a single bit
in the presence of additive noise but of
course there can also be more
complicated models in which we have more
complicated signals that are sent and
more complicated models of the noise but
the general principles of the analysis
are always of this kind we're using the
Bayes rule and we need to write down the
different terms that are involved